[موسيقى]
الانتخابات التركيه في 2023 انتخابات
مختلفه سياسيا واقتصاديا واجتماعيا هي
المره الاولى التي يواجه فيها اردوغان
تحالفا يضم سته احزاب معارضه بينها حزباني
كبيران كما انها ليست منافسه تقليديه بين
ائتلافين حاكم ومعارض بقدر ما هي صراع على
تحديد هويه تركيا في قرنها الثاني ومفترق
طريق ستسلكه البلاد باردوغان او بدونه
سواء كانت الانتخابات الرئاسيه او
البرلمانيه الثامنه والعشرين تحظى باهميه
واحده حيث تاتي بعد مرور 100 عام على
تاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
الطريق الذي ستنتهي به هذه الانتخابات في
حال فاز فيها اردوغان هو طريق قرن جديد
بوعود كبيره من قبل الرئيس التركي وفرصه
لتثبيت مشروعه السياسي اما خساره اردوغان
للرئاسه فقد تعني حقبه جديده داخليا
دستورا واصلاحات جديده وما تسعى له
المعارضه من خلال الاطاحه باردوغان بهدف
دخول حقبه جديده تبدا بالتراجع عن سياساته
داخليا اي منعطف تسلكه الانتخابات قد يعني
تغيرات توجهات تركيا الخارجيه خاصه الدوره
والتاثير التركيه في الشؤون الدوليه يمثل
تحديا للمعارضه فهو شهاده على انجازات
اردوغان عقدان كانت الفتره الاخيره الاصعب
فيهما فقد شهدت فيها تركيا متغيرات عده
اقتصاديه على راسها التضخم وكذلك كوارث
طبيعيه زلزال كان بمثابه اختبار للرئيس
التركي لذا فانما ستقرره صناديق الاقتراع
لن يتعلق فقط بمن سيحكم لكن بكيفيه الحكم
والمسار الاقتصادي الذي سيسلكه الفائز
وسياساته داخليا او خارجيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات